the incomparable goodness of coffee has
now been captured in a cup before
Starbucks I think in the mid-70s people
were drinking really bad coffee they
were drinking instant coffee Maxwell
House you ban and perking it at home and
it wasn't very good your first cup of
Starbucks coffee was in the pipe Play
Store in 1979 1980 was a French press of
Sumatra I think about four to five cups
of coffee a day what you see the doctors
to me it's they don't say that that's it
we just came for the baby thank you for
your comment hiya welcome thank you when
I came here for the first time had never
been in a Starbucks store walked into
this very store by the way we have
changed nothing through the year this is
the original store as is and they handed
me a cup of coffee made this way now
this is a cup of Sumatra which is
Indonesian coffee this is how I tasted
my first cup of coffee and I just knew
from that moment on that I was home that
I ever imagined that we would one day
have stores in 65 countries serving
almost 80 million customers a week No
growing up in Brooklyn in the projects
in the early 60s what I would loosely
describe is the other side of the tracks
provides a deep sense of understanding
that there's a world out there that's
very very different than the world that
is inside where we where we grew up
and I wanted to be part of that world
when I finished school I got hired by a
great company and that was your ox and I
worked there for a number of years but I
just didn't feel I belonged in a very
structured environment so I left Xerox
and I went to work for a large Swedish
company that was starting a US consumer
division in a very roundabout way they
had a customer in Seattle Washington
called Starbucks their aspiration at the
time was to expand to Portland Oregon I
somewhat persuaded them that perhaps
Starbucks opportunity was bigger and
they need to soar like me
if they understand Starbucks had three
stores in 82 but the core business was
just selling pounds of ground and
roasted coffee for home use a year after
I joined the company I went to Italy for
the first time person you can't walk
through any major city or town in Italy
without running into a coffee bar and
seeing the sense of community and
romance and theater around espresso it
just made me realize that Starbucks
perhaps was not in the right part of the
coffee business but the real business
and the opportunity was the integration
of the beverage to creating a
destination and sense of community in
the store what I experienced in Italy
was something that was transferable in
the u.s. ring for the first time great
coffee introduce new beverages that no
one ever heard of no one heard of a cafe
latte before I raced home to talk to the
founders about the experience I had and
they rejected it over a period of two
years
I left Starbucks to start my own chain
of Italian coffee bars at that time
Starbucks found itself in financial
difficulties and so the founder came to
me and said I can't think of Starbucks
in better hands and it was in your hands
I realize you don't have the money I'll
give you X amount of time to try and
find it I was able to buy Starbucks in
August of 87 they had six stores at the
time for 3.8 million dollars
I didn't at that point have an
understanding that coffee would one day
become part of the culture the zeitgeist
in ways that I couldn't possibly
understand or predict I think we
realized early on that what we had to do
is everything had to prove itself in the
cup the ability to source and roast the
highest quality Arabica beans in the
world gave us the platform to do things
that would define and build an industry
that did not exist many people at the
time were convinced Starbucks was too
strong we had to educate the market and
the customer about know this is what
coffee should taste like and there you
have it